in Washington a shocking reversal in the
criminal case of president Trump's
longtime friend and Ally Roger stone
it's led to a protest in charges of
interference for career prosecutors
withdrew from stones case after the
Justice Department rejected their
recommendation for seven to nine year
prison sentence
this morning the president praised
Attorney General William Bar for
stepping in Jeff Pegues is at the
Justice Department with more on this
story Jeff this was such a stunner when
it broke yesterday what are you hearing
there well DOJ officials insist that
they did not talk to the White House
about this sentencing but they did make
it clear that they were unhappy with the
prosecutors in this case but hours
before they made this decision to seek a
more lenient sentence the president was
tweeting calling the original
recommendation horrible and a
miscarriage of justice and then this
morning the president congratulate his
Attorney General for quote taking charge
of the case that was totally out of
control now keep in mind in November a
jury found stone guilty on all seven
counts against him including witness
tampering obstruction and lying to
Congress the case of course stemmed from
the investigation into Russia's meddling
in the 2016 election some Democratic
members of Congress are already calling
for an investigation into do Jays
actions however ultimately the
sentencing comes down to the judge judge
Amy Berman Jackson she is the same judge
who sentenced the former Trump campaign
chairman Paul Manafort totally back to
you alright Jeff we'll have to see what
that judge decides on February 20th
thank you very much